peace be with you welcome to the DS show
I'm Eddie your host subscribe if you
haven't already a lot to talk about
again Donald Trump and only two nations
that have been a relationship with God
or Israel in the United States of
America we're gonna learn more about
these two nations the only two they're
actually blessed by God and again we got
ben Carson with the Bible and our next
guest is gonna comment on this video
clip simple question does the Bible have
authority over the Constitution all this
and more on this exciting episode of the
D show don't go anywhere we'll be right
back peace be with you assalamualaikum
waalaikumsalam bro how are you my
brother doing well are you ready it's
good to have you back here everybody Wow
I know we're gonna get right into a true
story you're walking down the street man
approaches you says hey I saw you on the
D show maybe not quite like that but he
said I saw you on TV we had a really
nice conversation tell us about this
true story
absolutely basically I was walking down
the street one day and somebody said
that I saw you on the Dean show as you
meant I was the Dean show it was oh cool
yeah and basically he had seemed
basically had been following different
things that I've been doing on my social
media and one of them was a Dean show
another was CNN
yeah and he's proceeded to ask me
questions about Islam and Muslims and he
had a lot of detail on things like Anwar
al-awlaki where he was born he could you
know pronounce his name properly asked
me questions about Isis he knew the
geography there and then deep into the
conversation he asked me but just you
know this may sound a little silly but
clarify for me Arabs and Muslims which
one is the one that prays to Allah and I
was a little stunned that somebody who
had this kind of detail about terrorism
about Anwar al-awlaki and Isis knew very
little about the very basics of this
part of the world in the community that
he was purporting to talk about and he
proceeded to ask questions that were of
a biased nature given the fact that he
knew a lot about the aberrational but
very little by the normative and I used
the analogy that imagine if you were
somehow a cancer specialist or he
thought you were but you didn't know
where the heart was located in the body
and that's
of the situation we're dealing with here
and it dawned upon me that Islamophobia
is something that we talk about often
but in many a man with many Americans
it's simply a case of lack of
information of confusion of ignorance
and I say that not in a way to to
disparage but you know subjectively
they're just ignorant of the facts and
we have a lot of work to do and you're
doing a great job with it Eddie and
others are to educate people by the very
basics to let them know what the
normative state of Islam is how most
Muslims view Islam and practice their
religion and when we understand that
normative body then the way that we
behave normally then we can talk about
the exceptional scenarios of the
extremists of the zealots of the
terrorists etc within that larger
context but if we only talk about what
is extreme and aberrational and
exceptional and then draw broad and
general general generalizing type of
statements about the majority that's the
problem that we have we're gonna get
into Donald Trump and ben Carson but I
would think this is a good thing how do
at the end how did this conversation end
we want people to approach us no matter
how silly the question their ideas how
did it go at the end how overall if you
summarize it was it did you guys leave
off on a positive note yeah there's a
45-minute conversation why 45 minutes
yeah Mantic is time and this was a
person who is at a fortune 500 company
and executives so he was someone who
isn't ignorant in that sense as well
educated person generally speaking but
just didn't know anything about the
basics of Islam and Muslims so I was
happy to take his questions I try to be
as patient as possible he told me that
he was scared of women who wore the
hijab and I explained to him that the
hey job basically is little more than
covering the parts of your body that you
see as our on I explained what all it is
it's the part of the body that you can't
you know leave the house without
covering and I said you have that same
concept you're not going to go to work
shirtless and he thought about it and I
said well that's your hijab your shirt
is your head job you're covering that
part of your body that you deem
necessary before you leave the house
yeah for a Muslim some many Muslim women
it's also the hair it's also the head
it's also the neck and so it's not so
much a difference in concept between you
and them it's a difference in the extent
of the concept and you know he conceded
that point and several other points that
he
raised and I answered and at the end he
said you know I'm very thankful for this
conversation would like to keep it going
I gave him my phone number and office
address and invited him back for a
conversation so you know again it's
important for us to be able to
differentiate between those who are
maliciously Slama phobic and there are
such people who know better but have an
agenda and they pursue this agenda that
is hate that is bigotry and those who
are simply clueless and who need us to
stoop down and help lift them up with
information with knowledge with patience
and with a level of grace now I'm gonna
show you show our audience this clip and
I'm gonna get your comments on you know
what struck me the most honestly was
when I took a minute to actually talk to
some of the Muslim people to find out
you know they are just like me and I am
uneducated on their religion you know I
could easily make as many mistakes
judgment calls as any other person out
there but when I took a second to sit
down and listen to them and actually
enter their mosque in going and watch
some of their prayers it was a beautiful
thing and they answered some of my
questions that I had and I just feel
that maybe that that's something that
they should do too for the people a lot
a lot of us were uneducated you know
educate us on your religion let us know
that not everybody's a bad bad person
amazing the human connection look he
went into the mosque he saw wasn't about
making factory and he's calling he's
called it he's a he's a made he said
educate us on your religion what are
your thoughts in US I mean it it's
exactly an example of what I was just
talking about that there are many people
who we may deem Islamophobic at first
glance at first instance because of the
rhetoric that they engage in and
oftentimes it's similar to the one from
the maliciously intended
you know Islamophobic organized network
but we need to go back and analyze
difference between the majority of
Americans who may exhibit Islamophobic
rhetoric but just don't know any better
and our fair game for engagement and can
potentially change a man like this
and those who are agenda driven and sort
of rooted in hate and bigotry and we
needs to have different strategies we
can't have a one size fit all for the
you know sort of dyed-in-the-wool
Islamophobes
we
suppose we deconstruct and we engage in
refutations of their lives with
individuals like this and many Americans
who are like him we engage in education
in awareness building in shedding light
on the reality of Islam and Muslims
there was a Chicago scholar recently who
was with a student at a Starbucks and
his student you know looked at this man
who was in tattoos and whom he knew and
he said this guy's an atheist
look at this kafir and the scholar told
him he's you can't call him a kafir and
he said but but he doesn't believe in
God and he said but a kafir is someone
who covers the truth have you presented
him with the truth have you ever
attempted to present him with the truth
and then give him an opportunity to
cover it or not but simply given the
fact that he was never approached or
given any information you cannot call
this person a Katherine and so we have
an obligation as Muslims to share the
truth of what we know and to do it in a
way that is easy for others to
understand we need to understand our
audience and speak in a language a
culturally sensitive language that
people can understand these concepts and
it's not about proving our innocence
from terrorism this isn't about
apologizing for anything
I don't expect Muslims to walk around
and have to prove that they are not bad
people I don't want in any way for
Muslims to take on that kind of
responsibility but as people who love
their faith and who are more than happy
to share with others who are thirsty for
knowledge and for information what this
faith is about by all means do so in the
prophetic way the Quran describes it as
patience with grace with beautiful
advice with the good word it isn't with
anger it isn't with a sense of revenge
it isn't with a sense of bitterness or
hopelessness or despair it is the
prophetic way we're gonna take a break
we got a lot more we're going to talk
about the donald trump prayer he's
praying that's a good thing i'm gonna
see what he's praying about ben Carson
with the Bible a lot more to talk about
what our special guests here to dien
show don't go anywhere
salam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter page
using the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below back here on the D
show I'm in rehab director of care
Chicago tell us before we get into the
Donald Trump prayer talk to us about the
Islamophobia conundrum the catch-22
well the catch-22 is basically the
notion that Islamophobes will sort of
claim that Islam is a religion it's
problematic that there are verses in the
Quran that are violent or problematic in
other ways and then when you refute that
by saying first of all here's why you're
misunderstanding the verses and we're
happy to engage in apologetics and to
explain and clarify what these verses
mean it's not that we can't do that but
more importantly when we come back and
say wait a second let's look at the
Bible let's look at the Tanakh or the
Torah let's look at other religious
texts and you begin to list verses that
if given equal scrutiny to the verses in
the Quran that these individuals are
giving scrutiny to you will find that
there's a lot more violence a lot more
intensity a lot more of these verses in
these holy books and then you say
anybody can play this game right the
only difference between why slam gets
this bad rap and other religions don't
is because it slam gets more scrutiny by
people who are not scholars by people
who don't know how to read the text then
other religions get and then they turn
around and say well it's not you know
it's only Muslims or oh bombing people
well first of all that's not true it's
only Muslims are violent first of all
it's not true but then when you say
great let's talk about people and the
reason why people are violent now we're
talking about people he thinks we're not
talking about the religious texts
anymore that's a great place to be this
is where we need to be we talk about
economic factors we talk about political
ideologies we talk about geopolitical
factors we talk all about these human
factors and then they say well that's a
cop-out we need to go to Islam itself we
need to go to the holy book itself then
you're back to square one again and so
that's the catch-22 there I'm talking
about tell us what did you think about
the whole situation and how was handle
with
the Muslim who made the clock and then
he actually ended up Ahmed Mohammed yeah
would you take on this and how well
handled yeah I mean kicker has been very
vociferous on this issue and we handled
it in the media and we helped out the
family but basically it's a case of a
young boy who and there's been a lot of
debate recently especially after the
incident subsided about whether he's a
good inventor of an inventor that's not
the point he may have made a great clock
or a crappy clock that's not the point
the point is is a kid aspiring to do
something great with his life he wants
to be an engineering wants to be a
person involved in technology and that's
great
and so he volunteered this project and
brought it to his school to impress his
teacher and as a result was arrested and
a suspicion of either having a bomb or
playing a hoax which you obviously
shouldn't do either he was doing either
of these two things and he maintained
that all along and we believe in many
believe it's only because his name is
Ahmed and his you know a dark-skinned
young boy who is a Muslim that he was
viewed with such suspicion and rather
than you know applaud the young man and
give him credit for his efforts he was
cast as yet another potential terrorist
and that's a very very telling statement
on how many in this country still view
Islam and Muslims and so we wanted to
put light on this issue President Obama
commented on it you know positively
other people in technology did as well
the Mark Zuckerberg from Facebook Google
Yahoo other types of organizations and
you know MIT offered him I believe a
program in the summer so good things
came out of it and a good national
public conversation came out of it but
we really get need to get to a point
where we begin to look at people based
on their merit based on what they can
offer and have no glass ceilings on
anybody have nobody filled because
they're of a certain color or religion
that they have to watch out but they
have to be careful that they can't
really engage in their dreams because
others may misunderstand what they're
out to do that's exactly what we don't
want this is a free entrepreneurial
nation that's what made this nation
great to begin with and hate and bigotry
is the single most greatest threat to
the progress of this nation moving
forward more so than Isis more so than
Iran or southern Russia more so than
China it's all internal
domestic that's the greatest challenge
for our future before we get into the
Donald Trump prayer let's go to Ben
Benny Carson dr. ben Carson and get your
comments on on this simple question does
the Bible have authority over the
Constitution he said that's a simple
question
I know a simply worded question how's
that I think probably what you have to
do is ask a very specific question about
a specific passage of the Bible and a
specific portion of the Constitution I
don't think you can answer that question
other than out of very specific context
Carson clarified his comments yesterday
saying in an interview quote Muslims
feel that their religion is very much a
part of your public life and what you do
is a public official and that's
inconsistent with our principles we have
to stop listening to these people who
tell us that we cannot talk about God we
cannot talk about our faith every coin
in our pocket every bill in our wallet
says In God We Trust but we're not
supposed to talk about it what in the
world is that in medicine we call it
schizophrenia a form of craziness so do
you believe that Islam is consistent
with the Constitution no I don't I do
not I would not advocate that we put a
Muslim in charge of this nation I
absolutely would not agree with that he
said that's a simple question he said
that's a simple question you know
recently it's a big controversy you see
Ben Carson he made a statements about
early derogatory towards Islam and
Muslims and we did a show actually and
we asked him to comment about the
Christian Sharia right and now when he
was actually asked simple question does
the Bible have authority over the
Constitution regarding the Bible and the
Constitution it seemed like a difficult
question for him to answer what would
you say on this bigotry is one thing
that Ben Carson has been guilty of yeah
another is hypocrisy in this instance he
was asked a simple question it was in
fact a simple question simply and he
said this is not such a simple question
that's because it's a hypocrite that's
because he believes his religion
should may trump the Constitution when
he deems fit and many who support him
believe like him and then they turn
around and accused Muslims and Islam of
being a threat to the Constitution with
Sharia that's in fact not at all true
first of all Muslims in this country are
2 million people according to some
Paul's 6 to 7 million according to
others we're talking with his group of
people 50 to 60 million
you know evangelicals right-wing
Christians etc who believe in the Bible
Trump in the Constitution now when you
look at the Muslim community that's not
the direction we're going we're not
interested in Sharia pipping the
Constitution Sharia something that can
be practiced without in any way
conflicting with the Constitution in
personal affairs and that's the
direction we've taken that's the extent
of it there's no interest there's no
movement there's no money being pumped
in there there are no candidates being
run in order to do otherwise at the
federal level of the state level at any
government level like what his community
is doing secondly when you talk about
that group of people you're talking
about billions of dollars are being
raised it's not just that there are 50
to 60 million people but billions of
dollars in political power money and
then they're running cannabis yeah Mike
Huckabee they have this guy they have
others to have a tea party have you
heard of the Hubble hookah party I
haven't you know the tea parties the one
that's out there yeah Muslims aren't
putting together you know a massive
movement to put the quran above the
constitution the way that group of
people are doing with the bible to pick
the constitution so here's a hypocrite
in that in that sense and oftentimes you
see this sharia scare as being nothing
more than mirrors and smoke screens to
sort of deflect attention and point at
someone else this is projection and say
their religion is going to threaten our
constitution whereas that's exactly what
the evangelical right-wing christian
movements in this country and their
candidates and there are super PACs and
their websites and their blogs and their
TV stations on cable AM radio etc are
essentially out to do and that is the
religious threat to this constitution
that many people are not talking about
there's a real big lot of hypocrisy
double standard we're going to pick up
here with and finish off with the prayer
to Donald Trump prayer to job in waiting
for here in the Dean show don't go
anywhere salam says love all mankind
that's why we're sharing this message
because we want the best for you and we
want the best for all mankind please
subscribe to the DCO follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and what you've been
waiting for
I mean prayer is a good thing and we we
include everyone I mean we'd like to we
ask God Almighty that he blesses you
know this nation that he guides all
humanity to that which will give us
purpose that will help us live our
purpose to help us you know really do
what the Creator wants us to do and to
bless all of us you know and but this is
an interesting prayer I wanted to get
your your comments on we're gonna go to
this clip and only two nations that have
ever been a relationship with God or
Israel in the United States of America
father God in your shoe astanga you
bring this man into the Oval Office I
speak your blessing over for the same
people yes you have a recognized Yahweh
Bheeshma Resco in Jesus name
okay so I want to share it
true story with you now shakes driving
in a car with some of his students and
you know some of the traffic on goers I
letting him go in he saying Gisella
hydro and jazakallah hydro and the
students are saying what are you doing
shaking you saying you know these are
not Muslims you say may God reward him
he said of course you know we want the
best for everybody and what greater
reward than guidance for all of mankind
so we don't exclude anybody so my
concern here was the statement where the
gentleman who was kind of had his palm
in Donald Trump's face messing up his
hairdo the Python maneuver there yeah
yeah I think this is more con for some
so he excluded he included two nations
but he excluded the rest of Bank what
are your comments um
well first of all again going back to
Hippocrates it's great that there's
prayer like you said for the reasons
that you mentioned but something tells
me that Donald Trump has never had a
prayer session in his board room before
and this doesn't look very genuine to me
and the people that you brought on are
very shady characters for those who know
a little about some of these people that
are there but then this quote-unquote
rabbi from Jews for Jesus is saying that
only two nations been blessed or right
by God the United States and Israel I
don't know what scripture is referring
to there but even in the interesting
intent of saying something like this
betrays the mindset of supremacy that
exists with supporters of this kind of
far-right thinking and excludes the rest
of the world from God's blessings which
is at the very least extreme I mean we
can call this person a religious
extremist zealot etc and it's funny
because it's such people people that are
present in this room that run around the
media and on the blogosphere trying to
suggest that we Muslims are extremists
the mainstream Muslims whereas in our
faith we don't have something that is
similar to this something that says only
you know the Mecca is blessed by God I
mean we believe the entire world
the universe is a Dominion the minion of
God and he blesses all of his creatures
as he deems fit and his ultimate wisdom
etc so it's projection once again it's
religious extremists projecting their
own extremism on someone else whereas
they're the culprits of that kind of
thinking and you see it here at the
level of a presidential candidate a
front-runner in one of the main parties
political parties in this country so
it's quite scary to me there is an
element of comedy so it's a bit comical
the way it looks and feels and I don't
mean that to disparage the religious
beliefs of people who are are there or
who support people who are there but
just the begin the hypocrisy of it all
the fact that it's Donald Trump the fact
that he's standing there a very awkward
way and not feeling comfortable with
what's going on but still going forward
with it to try to get some votes etc is
very comical to me there was also a I'm
sure you've seen the video where a
questioner had asked Donald Trump we
have problem in this country it's called
Muslims we know our current president is
one well you know he's not even an
American we need this
but anyway we have training camps
growing will they want to kill us
hmm that's my question when can we get
rid of we're gonna be looking at a lot
of different things yep basically when
are we gonna get rid of them referring
to the Muslims now obviously I mean you
can see if this was something that was
referring to getting rid of maybe Jews
maybe get rid of African Americans or
any other group of people I mean this
this would really
unfortunately particularly with the with
the GOP but every time there is a
presidential campaign or a political
campaign of high exposure we see an
uptick in Islamophobic rhetoric the
Muslim community still deemed as the
weak link by some that it's fair game to
sort of slap down and get away with it
and maybe win some votes through the
scare mongering and fear-mongering
factor and Donald Trump played to that I
think given his success in life at least
at the financial level he's smart enough
to know that this guy statement is wack
it's completely ridiculous yet still he
pander to it and said yeah you know
there's a lot of bad things out there
we're going to look at all of them he
should have stopped this man dead in his
tracks and said this is what you're
saying is ridiculous we don't get rid of
millions of Americans based on their
faith that's something that Nazi Germany
tried to do this man was was was asking
for Donald Trump to to support a sort of
Nazi Germany version of the United
States and he and he ran away with it he
took the pill and didn't really you know
shoot it down so it's very problematic
for me that he played along with that
I think Jason ledger should be a great
example for anybody who was planning on
protesting we're probably almost
wrapping up let's go to this final clip
here and the way they opened may you
know welcomed me with open arms they
invited me and my uncle Paul back to
Majer nin their prayer and ask any
questions that we may have they were
glad the answer for us I mean that's
what struck me amazing about the people
is once I came inside there was no
hostility there was no anger like what
was going on outside
we're being painted as the hostile ones
Jason Ledger he went into a mush Jed and
actually one in woulda F aslam T sure
now you've imagined you know if it was
like F the Holocaust or the Jews or
whatever and then the the people
inviting him in probably wouldn't happen
after going into a one of the African
American neighborhoods F and I'd you
know this derogatory terms the Muslim F
Islam and they came in didn't he didn't
experience any hostility he really
experienced open open arms so this is a
great example for the rest of our
brothers in humanity to follow to come
in and speak to the Muslims what would
you say about this you're absolutely
right and credit to the individuals of
the mosque who practiced patience and
wisdom and character in engaging this
man with the good word with with
beautiful advice with grace and with
patience just like the Quran teaches and
just like our prophet behaved in his
lifetime and let's remember a lot of the
Sahaba the Companions of the Prophet
people that we deem in in high
noble a Nobel level in our in our faith
our people who once upon a time did not
believe in God once upon a time were
even very much against Islam perhaps
even violently with language but also
physically and the prophets patience and
grace and wisdom and beautiful advice
helped win their hearts over and I want
to clarify something here Dawa or
inviting people to God in Islam does not
necessarily mean converting them because
God guides hearts we shouldn't be out to
try to win one for the team
this isn't about expanding the religion
Dawa really is about representing the
values of your faith for the sake of God
the only audience worth addressing is
God we're not looking for it you know
pat on the back from anybody in behaving
the way we do we're not looking for a
positive media we're not looking to
impress you know Jason or anybody else
we're looking to address God who asked
us to behave in this way the
consequences of doing this is positive
they may impress with the media being
present but that's not the point and
secondly it is about values it is about
trying to guide people like Jason to the
values of patience of intellectual
disposition of critical thinking of
positive and elevated human behavior if
we're able to do that that is the dawa
that our religion is for should someone
as a result accept the oneness of God
the prophethood of the Prophet Muhammad
son Allah send them etcetera great if
that's what works for them and that's
what guys their hearts wonderful but
ultimately we shouldn't be too obsessed
as some people endow our with conversion
and converting people to the religion
but rather showing the value of this
religion and letting that take people in
whatever journey that they may
absolutely tell us we're out of time
people want to hook up with you your
organization tell us about how they can
get a contact with you to learn more
about your work yeah well Kerr Chicago
is the office the Chicago office of the
Council on american-islamic relations
here in Chicago and we're located at 17
North State in downtown Chicago off of
State and Madison our phone numbers 3 1
2 2 1 2 1 5 2 0
our website is
org and our emails info at care Chicago
org we are in the business of defending
the Muslim American community against
Islamophobia bigotry racism etc we do so
through the media through education
through awareness but also through civil
rights cases where there are violations
we take on the cases that meet our
criteria and we can take them all the
way to the court system and usually we
win these cases because we know what
we're doing and we have the support of
our community we have great lawyers
working with us so if you face
discrimination if you face the civil
rights violation you can consult with us
we'll be happy to help you if you see
anything in the media or elsewhere that
is bigoted and you you want to draw our
attention to it so that we can handle it
and deal with it
please contact us at the information
mentioned we started with peace we end
with peace may God bless you and reward
you for being with us
Salaam alaikum and thank you for tuning
in to the Deen show as our guests had so
eloquently explained that it is not our
job to try to convert anybody it's to
share because we truly care and we want
the best for all of mankind so when you
live how a Muslim supposed to live with
the best character in the best manners
and at the same time you share with our
brothers and sisters in humanity and you
open up these mustards like Jason Ledger
was invited in and he got a whole new
perspective on Islam and Muslims so
continue to tune into the Deen show to
learn about the most misunderstood way
of life in the world Islam yet the
fastest-growing and call us anytime
1-866 to Islam subscribe if you haven't
already and we'll see you next time
God willing until then peace be with you
sir